you're watching the daily climate show
here on Sky News coming up on today's
program coal power plants forced to
close in India as pollution levels see a
rise in Hospital admissions
nine insulate Britain climate change
activists jails for breaching an
injunction by blocking the M25
Wells uses a trip to Jordan to warm the
world to stop mucking about on climate
change
foreign
[Music]
hello there and welcome to the UK's only
daily climate news show where we track
the changes happening to our world right
now and challenge those who are coming
up with the solutions our top story
tonight a toxic mix of pollutants
blanketing New Delhi India's capital in
a thick smog is causing serious health
issues for children and as forced
authorities to close schools and
temporarily shut some coal-powered
plants India gets more than 70 percent
of all its energy from coal and has been
internationally criticized for a last
minute intervention at the cop 26
climate Summit in Glasgow now it meant
the language on coal was changed from
phase out to phase down in that final
agreement and now the country's Supreme
Court is deliberating where the New
Delhi should go into a lockdown to
protect residents well the air quality
index rates a healthy level of air
pollution as being between naught to to
50 PM 2.5 that metric refers to the tiny
particles that clog people's lungs now
between 151 and 200 is considered
unhealthy another thing between 301 and
500 is hazardous now in the past week
some parts of New Delhi peaked at 500 on
several occasions indicating healthy
people were at risk of developing severe
respiratory illnesses now let's compare
that to the city of London at its
highest point this week levels reached
15 well within what is considered
healthy as you can see there now an
Amita rachoudry is the executive
director at the Center for Science and
environment in New Delhi I spoke to her
earlier and began by asking if the
situation was worse now than in previous
years
when these are very cool and calm
conditions there is no wind in the city
there is winter inversion and as a
result what happens the air gets trapped
and with that whatever pollution that is
happening in the city or coming from
outside all gets trapped and suddenly we
see this spiraling of pollution level
now we cannot do anything about the
weather every winter we are going to see
this kind of weather but what we can
certainly address is the pollution and
that's where the big concern is today
that because the pollution levels are
high in the region so as soon as the
weather turns adverse it kind of begins
to build up it does sound particularly
bad at the moment I just wanted to ask
you about cop 26 because of course at
the end of that in the final statement
uh India was behind the watering down
when it came to Coal
um there's an irony isn't there that
many of delhi's coal-fired power
stations have just been ordered to stop
operating rating because of this
pollution all of us who want you know
you know sensitive
Brooklyn energy
and what India is saying today and what
is coming from the huge energy poverty
that we have in this country but at the
same time I'm going to go join that with
the other position that India took when
India and cop 26 has also raised the
level of the ambition saying that it's
going to cut billion tons of carbon by
2030 if that translates that now into
domestic policy then we are going to get
the co-benefit of reducing carbon
emissions but at the same time the
life-threatening local air pollution in
the next few years coal consumption is
expected to grow in absolute terms in
India so in the in the next few years do
you think the pollution will just get
worse and worse
in absolute terms there might be will be
some increase by 2030 but the in the
share of the coal is certainly going to
reduce now if we can stay on track for a
renewable energy commitment and push
that agenda hard then certainly we will
be able to curb that growth but we have
to address this in a way that we do the
environmental justice where we give the
clean energy to the poor but poor also
have access to energy and that's the
double whammy and the challenge for
India yeah indeed the animator Roy
choudhary great to get your analysis
thank you very much
thank you
well let's take a look then at what is
happening globally with the missions we
can take a look at our data dashboard it
shows the global CO2 emissions and as
you can see that number ticking up of
course all the time and here is the
powermix in Great Britain at the moment
Gas makes up 39.9 coal is zero percent
today Renewables 33.4 and nuclear at
13.4 percent
now in some of today's other climate
news nine insulate Britain activists
have been jailed for breaching an
injunction by blocking the M25 they've
been sentenced to between three and six
months for causing disruption on one of
the country's busiest roads the group
remain undeterred saying they will
continue to protest until the government
agrees to insulate homes
we are here to tell you the reality of
our situation the next three to four
years matter everything we do every day
for the next three to four years matters
for all of our children for all of our
futures so they're asking us are we
going to stop no
thank you
Farmers have used jet skis and canoes to
rescue dozens of cows from a flooded
Farm in Abbotsford in British Columbia
around 50 cows were evacuated after two
days of heavy rain caused flooding and
landslides across the region
the US government is auctioning off more
than 80 million Acres of the Gulf of
Mexico for fossil fuel extraction all
companies including shell and BP have
bid on drilling leases which together
would produce an estimated 1.1 billion
barrels of oil over the next 50 years
environmental groups have called the
move Reckless and damaging
now the Prince of Wales has used his
first foreign trip since the pandemic to
keep up momentum on tackling climate
change after cop 26 in Glasgow while in
Jordan Prince Charles said water food
and energy are critical and it's the
private sector which holds the key to
climate Solutions
this time job as we cannot go on mucking
about any longer because the urgencies I
was trying to say is so great which is
why I've been trying to develop this
sustainable Market solution with the
private sector which I've always
believed holes that the basic key to the
solutions
Prince Charles speaking a little earlier
today Scottish Royal correspondent
Rhiannon Mills has the latest now from
Jordan
so yeah this is the first time that the
Prince of Wales since those negotiations
concluded at 26 has been asked directly
about how he's he's feeling about those
negotiations and the conclusions and I
think for me what was really interesting
is it's a sensitive one for him he
doesn't want to criticize those who were
at cop and carrying out those
negotiations but still very forceful in
what he had to say in terms of the fact
that he says the problem is we cannot go
on mucking about any longer because the
urgency as I was trying to say is so
great he also was very keen to talk to
me about something that he was pushing
very heavily at cop 26 which was the
fact that the private sector need to
work with the public sector and only by
unleashing money within the business
world can we really face those
challenges that we have to address with
the climate crisis being here in Jordan
also he said is a major example of that
um he's already been carrying out
engagements where they've been focusing
on the scarcity of resources
particularly the issue of water because
here in Jordan they have enough water
for a population of 2 million but
actually they have a population of 10
million and that's partly because
they've been so willing over the years
to take in so many refugees and there
are fears here in Jordan that if
something isn't done about this then by
2040 aquifers and the water table could
run dry of course however here in Jordan
they are already looking at innovative
solutions and actually when it comes to
Renewables they are very well placed so
many Wide Open Spaces that they could
use for for example solar energy and
also wind power but I think for the
Prince of Wales the important thing is
again shining a light on Nations that do
have challenges but also looking ahead
at potential Solutions
Rihanna Mills there back here in the RAF
has won a Guinness World Record for the
world's first successful flight using a
synthetic fuel now the plane was powered
by zero petroleum made using hydrogen
extracted from water and carbon taken
from CO2 in the atmosphere
[Music]
so for the Air Force it's a small step
forwards but it's a huge step forwards
in many respects it's the start of our
journey to become Net Zero carbon by
2040.
foreign
[Music]
looks just like the gasoline we all know
when we've filled up our cars what we're
doing here is reversing the process of
combustion combining those ingredients
we make the hydrocarbon products which
in this case is gasoline
confetti fuel is really key to the Air
Force we're working with a range of
technologists and a range of
Technologies across our Fleet for our
current aircraft and our future aircraft
but where we're looking to get to is
even within the next few years being
able to power a Jets fully off this fuel
reduce the carbon footprint of our fast
air while still meeting our national
security commitments
do stay with us coming up after the
break I'll be joined by Mikhail nakmani
from climate policy radar and the
climate scientist Michael E Mann will be
discussing whether anything has changed
after cop 26 or is it back to business
as usual don't go away
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
these last few years have seen
have huge stories
[Music]
and these stories have been driven by
politics by politicians the people in
power you must stay at home and it's my
job to figure out how these decisions
made by politicians impact all of us in
our everyday lives this is the worst
thing I've ever been through in my life
people turn up here with their child's
stuff in a black sack and just say I
don't want to and that is what it is
it's first class profiter is this an
example of the welfare state failing we
take you to the heart of the stories
that shape our world these are stories
that affect us all
billions of children are now having to
catch up some stories have changed all
of our Lives because like the residents
the staff are being infected politicians
they make decisions all of the time and
it's our job to hold them to account I
wonder if you will take this opportunity
to apologize to those families but in
the end the real power doesn't actually
lie with the politicians
real power lies with the people
I'm Nick Martin I'm the people and
politics correspondent at Sky News
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
did you know if we tried to use less
energy we could help reduce air
pollution
what like turning off the lights and
stuff yeah
the north and west will have a rather
gray morning with fog and occasional
drizzle on the hills and heavier more
prolonged outbreaks over Western
Scotland elsewhere most places will be
dry and quite Sunny it'll be very mild
but it will be windy especially in the
north northwest Scotland will stay dull
and damp through the afternoon and the
northern Isles will turn wet but other
northern and western parts will become
drier and a bit brighter The Damp Breezy
conditions mean air pollution levels
will stay low
the air quality report sponsored by
Philips air purifiers
hello again welcome back to the Daily
climate show here on Sky News and we're
getting straight into discussing the
climate issues of the day tonight with
Dr Michael nachmani chief executive of
climate policy radar and Michael E Mann
distinguished professor of atmospheric
science and director of Earth Systems
Science Center at Penn State University
great to see you both this evening
thanks very much for being with us
Michael just reflecting then on our top
story this evening we know that India
weakened the final text in Glasgow when
it came to coal and here we are just a
few days later seeing that horrific
pollution in New Delhi you can
understand why critics say things like
cop26 simply don't achieve enough
yeah well you know there is some irony
there um in fact one of the things that
has gotten China to act more
substantially on issues of air pollution
and climate change has been the uh you
know the very dangerous uh air quality
issues that they've faced um in recent
years and so hopefully this is a
reminder to India of just how important
it is to act now now it's sort of a
complicated situation
um when it comes to India and their role
in the latest negotiations now they did
make a commitment for the first time to
eventually reach Net Zero carbon
emissions uh in 2070. so that's kicking
the can pretty far down the road but it
was enough actually that when you do the
revised calculations of the net warming
given all of the commitments that have
been made up through cop 26. for the
first time ever the warming came in
below two degrees Celsius so that's real
progress going into cop 21 on the Paris
Summit we were headed towards four
degrees uh warming so that was helpful
on the part of India on the other hand
as you've already alluded to they did uh
almost single-handedly force of watering
down of the language in the final
agreement uh which was changing uh the
commitment from phasing out call to
phasing down coal now it's easy to blame
India but in part their frustrations
arise from the fact that the industrial
economies of the world haven't yet
emptied up they haven't provided the
funding that they had committed to
provide to help developing countries
LeapFrog past the fossil fuel stage so
they can develop clean energy
infrastructure it needs to be
economically advantageous for them to do
so and that means more support from the
industrial world to help them yeah of
course
um Mikhail it'd be good to get your
thoughts on on India
situation by 2070 that Michael was
talking about what did you think when
you you you heard the Prime Minister say
that
[Music]
the
happen is that both the policy sector
and the private sector is a as uh the
Prince of Wales uh alluded to hold a
really
um significant key to unlocking progress
that is much faster the faster that we
develop Technologies the more the prices
are going to drop the more
infrastructure is going to be built the
sooner these things can happen these are
virtuous circles that we can get into
when we think about uh progress in 2070
is a statement that is intended to draw
uh attention and that says we need more
money we need more investment we need
more support and we need you to do your
part because Net Zero by 2050 doesn't
mean everyone reaches uh 2050 at the
same moment Net Zero at the same moment
it means that some countries reach Net
Zero earlier so the global average can
be
um it can hold global warming to no more
than 1.5 degrees and eventually lower
than that that is a goal that we'll have
to get to later we need to remember that
India has four million people relying on
coal
um as workers and we need to take care
of those people as well and we need to
remember that many Indians do not have
access to energy and decentralized
renewable energy will be uh will go a
long way in supporting energy access
yeah it's a really good point you make
there
um Michael we know that India also made
a very significant pledge when it comes
to renewable energy and we're going to
need the private sector aren't we to to
really help that come along and actually
as Mikhail was was saying there's no
reason why the private sector shouldn't
be excited and enthused by that and even
go to Greater lengths than India are
hoping for
now that's right I mean you know one of
the the things that we neglect is that
there has been a lot of progress now uh
not just on the governmental side and
perhaps Less on that side than we would
have liked coming out of crop 26 but
there are now real commitments from the
private sector in particular the finance
uh and investment industry increasingly
moving away from funding new fossil fuel
projects new fossil fuel infrastructure
and that's going to be critical because
we have right now what you might rightly
call an implementation gap on the one
hand we have these commitments from
various countries to lower carbon
emissions dramatically over the next
decade but in these same countries in
the UK here in the United States we're
continuing to see the green lighting of
new gas and oil pipelines and coal-fired
power plants and that's fundamentally
inconsistent with the pledges that these
countries have made we have to close
that implementation Gap and the private
sector can be very helpful in doing that
by no longer providing funding for new
coal projects in particular they can
really help out here and that is
starting to happen and it's making a
difference yeah I'll ask you about one
of those green lighting processes uh in
a moment Michael but Mikhail just
finishing on on cop26
um we discussed last night whether it
was fit for purpose as a process the
whole the whole cop scenario do you
think it still is are you say are you
still happy with the process do you
think in a year's time in Egypt we'll
make further gains and and move further
forward
so I think we need to remember that cop
26 happens I mean what happened in
Glasgow is things that happen in the
negotiation room and uh and Global
pledges and everything that happens in
the policy sphere but alongside that
many other things happen commitments on
finance happen investors see seek new
technologies and invest in new startups
data knowledge flows are facilitated
protesters protest people are engaged
all of these things create this
ecosystem of action that has actually
worked and if we think about a top-down
approach like we tried in Kyoto which
didn't really work but the bottom-up
approach that really facilitates local
knowledge and action and a much broader
participation as facilitated by the
Paris agreement and as can be seen in
Glasgow and next year in we will be I
think in a better place every year and
every year as long as we don't um give
up and giving up on this process is
something that I think is detrimental to
all of us and we really shouldn't do
that we should criticize it we should
improve it but we shouldn't give up on
it yeah it was good to see so many
indigenous communities wasn't it in
Glasgow trying to trying to make their
voices heard um Michael let's turn our
attention then to the United States Joe
Biden vowed the U.S will lead by example
didn't he when it comes to tackling
climate change and yet today the largest
ever sale of oil and gas drilling leases
in the Gulf of Mexico it's incredible
isn't it
well it's very frustrating to us I I
imagine it's quite frustrating to the
administration because they did indeed
try to stop
um all new fossil fuel uh infrastructure
and public lands um the courts have
pushed them back now we have a very
conservative court system right now
because of the appointments that were
made during four years of the Trump
Administration and because of that the
courts are essentially blocking many of
the actions that the executive branch
that the Biden Administration
um is trying to take and you know in the
end that puts even more pressure on the
climate Provisions uh that are being
considered legislatively uh and this
build back better bill in the United
States is still in limbo but if that is
passed with the climate Provisions
intact then it provides some real
mechanisms to help the United States
decarbonize its economy and its
infrastructure even in the face of some
of the opposition that we're still
encountering obviously by the fossil
fuel industry and by a conservative
court system that is sympathetic and has
actually been doing the bidding of the
fossil fuel industry rather than the the
bidding of the people they're supposed
to be representing yeah um Mikhail just
a very quick thought on this from you if
you could is the president talking the
talk but being stopped from walking the
walk
I think uh Michael's point on the court
system is a very interesting one and we
can see actually uh different court
systems around the world reacting in in
different ways and the way that
administrations are are constructed
around the world
um uh is significant uh for
understanding that relationship we do
see courts in other countries holding uh
corporates to account like the latest
shell ruling in the Netherlands and we
can see them taking governments to
account both in the Netherlands and in
Ireland and in other places and I think
this uh this relationship is a critical
one to um Mikhail I'm sorry to have to
stop you there Michael thank you both
very much